I really want you guys to smell no I'm
not smelling your fingers please oh no
isn't it Oh what's up you salty salmon
slice that's gonna be every time I host
an episode that's gonna be my theme oh
that's gonna be the new intro that's a
thing working on well welcome to the
trash taste podcast the show where we
talk trash about a taste in anime I'm
your host for today Joey and joined as
always is God and Connor yo so this
episode is uh I guess the first special
episode yeah yeah speed off every if
your being linked from our main channel
videos hello local podcast um but if you
haven't seen our main Channel videos do
we want to explain what we did oh yeah
sure so basically on our main channel we
decided to do like a little fun
challenge where as you can see our
backdrop is a little bonus this is a big
table that has a lot of potential space
to be filled up with some Wiebe [ __ ] yes
so what we decided to do is we decided
to venture out into the web land itself
Akihabara in Tokyo which is like known
as like heaven for tacos as it is and we
decided to challenge ourselves to see
how many figurines or I guess anime much
we can buy with a $500 budget or about
50,000 yen if you convert it to yes and
just instead of just going out of making
it like a vlog kind of thing we decided
to turn it into a challenge where we
fight each other let's make it fun let's
make it challenging and let's make let's
put some stakes on that's making the
relaxing experience into stressful Hell
where you guys shoot they don't want to
meet a dumb set of criteria so
essentially we gave ourselves a number
of challenges we had some small
challenges that we did in the four anime
stores that we went to in our main
Channel videos again if you want to
check it out go check it almost a lot of
context if you don't watch that
but if you haven't seen it and you
refuse to for some reason you'll still
be fine to watch this clock yes so
basically we all have scores already
from challenges that we went to with
that we did in each store which is
probably on screen right now yeah you'd
know that if you've watched our videos
but here are all our scores yep but it's
not the final score like any good mario
party game right it doesn't matter how
many stars you end up with it's all
about the final count it's all about the
bonus stars and this episode is
essentially where we go over the bonus
stars as well as show each other what we
got because right now we don't know what
the [ __ ] each other got no we maybe got
like a few glimpses as we like past each
other passive-aggressively in each of
the stores but right now we have no idea
what the other person board yes so
that's what we're gonna find out today
so we have a bunch of overarching
challenges right yes so we have some
that like pretty obvious like who spent
the most on a single figurine what was
that what who bought a figure from the
most popular series which will you lose
a point if that's the case nor me
awarded normal or we'll go over every
challenge at the end after we've
finished showing everyone what we've
bought um but for now I just wanted to
ask you guys we just filmed it yesterday
yeah how did you guys find the
experience I mean I found it super fun
that came out like I haven't started
editing the video yet as I am recording
this episode but I can already tell that
video is gonna be so [ __ ] fun too
yeah I feel like it's just fun like
that's like the narrator you can see I'm
having fun in it cuz there's like a kid
in a candy store right like the same why
we always go to these very expensive we
always go to these stores and being it
was like filming there with permission
we you know we want to be here
professionally we did we didn't Logan
pour this yeah God permission because we
respect we respect yeah we got all
pressure in stores and it's great
because you can't just got to let loose
in this store I mean some of us also
have people in there so I'll still try
to be respectful but yeah you know like
anime we were there's no one else in
that spot we've got in like before the
story yeah yeah when we left the store
there was like a massive queue of people
I I feel kind of bad right now
like crimes yeah look at these peasants
oh yeah like a lot of the stores were
like very happy to have us I mean like
amiami made us like sign that way yeah
if you ever go to army army in Akihabara
look out for a little plaque yeah we
have a trash tastes like plaque hang
that up is like no but all of the stores
were super freaking cool they're very
very supportive so first of all be shout
outs all the stores that did give us
permission to film there yeah but yeah
without further ado I think we should go
over what we bought in his store and
judge our as the name suggests track
based on figurines let's just before we
jump right in let's just hold off on the
jump okay I want to discuss so did you
guys have any strategy going into this
game or into this challenge even I said
I did in my main channel video but in
retrospect I did if if I win it was all
plans I was just having a fun choice you
know I think that's okay if you go
hundred percent honest I like had some
idea but I think it my strategy was just
see what you guys are doing so yeah I so
trying to go off all the challenges and
yeah I could see you guys have paying
attention like okay I was gonna but if I
knew that's because I could tell someone
you won pain as much attention to the
challenges as others I'm sorry the only
challenge that I paid in mind too was
only one that I remembered which was the
whoever gets closest to $500 we're
taking about two points yeah we just
what two points I'm like I have to
prioritize that two points is big whose
voice is big but like I remember because
I couldn't even remember what the
challenges are we agreed on so I went to
into you the day being like okay this
one's an obvious challenge this one's an
obvious challenge as I went into more
stores I was like I am not keeping track
of money I don't know what's happening
when wells Wells when I was in animate
I'm like okay I'm gonna do this in this
store do this in that store and then I
hit the second store I'm like what the
[ __ ] am i doing
oh I was so short decided on like the
challenges that I had to do in that's
yeah to put it in perspective we got two
challenges for every story produce on
the video we're so rich is a total of
eight points that we could get there's
ten eleven points up for grabs in the
overarching yes yes so I mean if you do
really well on the overarching
challenges it might not [ __ ] matter
yeah yeah exactly like we're already
close yeah I'm eight seven six right now
I might be losing but like any good
mario party game I can always come back
animate I didn't I didn't buy much in
this story I was the first why I'm gonna
pull the trigger okay so here's the I
didn't know how much I should boss
revealing right now or what do we do I
mean who wants to go first
I mean okay oh can I kill the host again
I'll go first because I only bought one
thing at a time okay so one of my
challenges was to get a maid in abyss
figurine yeah couldn't find it not even
not just an animate any of the storm but
I figured you know what I'll get
something like kind of cool and kind of
niche so I got Chucky mother from door
or oh yeah it's an Android of Chucky
mother and I mean it was so [ __ ] yeah I
love me my physical Samus stuff and I
love da door and I was like you know I
like my name droids - really really cute
I mean we will probably figure out the
pose of it somehow but that's the
special thing about nan droids you just
have to you go to pick one pose and
that's it's never good we all know it's
never good also see Nikki as well but
once you've like nailed it you like
Haley exactly yeah so that's the only
thing I got cuz yeah I got a few things
I have no um so it's I I had two
challenges right and I think I got
[ __ ] over over some of the overarching
challenges by by just animates itself
really okay let's let's go ahead so the
first thing the first challenge was to
buy a Deku figure from my hero academia
oh yeah
so yeah as we all know one of the
overarching challenges was the word the
person who buys
figure from the most popular series
getting deduct at a point yeah yeah so
there's there's my deck I was actually
getting bit worried right because there
weren't many like figures in really
varied yes so the only thing I could
find on Nendoroids and so my second
challenge was to ask a store clerk
what is Japanese to recommend me what
have you recommend you again he
recommended to me one he recommends me
the figure from the one series
you've just made me also lose a point by
recommending to me a check I checked for
the fourth most popular anime series on
Mouse cuz you see the price there that
that's 48 bucks right yeah how much I
spend on these two please this one says
48 88 and this one says that was like
about 550 to buy oh you know this one
will be a little bit more expand she's
got done dirty by that man yeah I was
like I in the videos like oh thank you
very much for recommending so yeah
that's what I'm just like oh I can't
believe you've done this thing which I
checked which cracks me up
yeah which is an Ishtar plushie it's
finished ah it's cute it's kind of I
like you I like
it's like it's like a giant Simpson yeah
uh $120 Jesus I only spent was just 30
bucks
yeah oh my god I only spent 48 yeah so I
will spend 48 bucks yeah oh my so I was
looking at that one hi my two challenges
will get a female figure and get one
from a show that you watched recently
and I watched like a few episodes like
two months ago so yeah why didn't you
get the nesco figure I saw your figure
and I'm like [ __ ] fight the
Normie award and I knew that do you
flares of the motion or whatever the
rankings say I've lost the Normie award
at heart
yeah and plus you know I want to risk it
all so I thought you know it's kind of a
cool figure yeah oh yeah yeah yeah it is
if we have Nezzer KO it when she's what
like fake anime fans get the [ __ ] out
man I think God has like fulfilled
prophecy the Boomer of Annie trivia tell
me about why massacre is you know I've
gone like how many episodes and I've not
talked about you Moto's yeah you you are
you're taking this chance to just give
us some time okay for the record I hate
nan droids I think nan droids are like
stressful purchases and we have four
goddamn mandroids
cuz you have to post them right and and
the whole best selling point of an
Android I'm pretty never gonna be
sponsored by an Android over the whole
selling point of an Android is that you
can move it but tell me everyone who
owns an Android when have you changed
the pose of an Android I change it a few
times
let's lie I've never changed yes he's
lying I've changed it because I'm
sponsored by this mark thanks guys it's
stressful and then you got to worry
about the box and the little things I
just I sometimes like where I'm just
like I look at the little pop and I'm
like I want to change it eventually and
then I do and I'm like okay I'm glad
okay actually before we go on question
to you guys what do you do with a figure
box do you been out or just office I
store
[ __ ] man I ripped that [ __ ] off the
value the mentality for me is like if I
eventually like possibly get like you
know I'm gonna sell this figure yeah
[ __ ] off you know you gonna sell this
video that's me I'm like oh maybe I can
sell this Jojo mark what helped me at my
last place is that it makes moving house
so much easier yeah if you keep the boss
sure because you like
I usually what what I do at least with
figurines right is like I throw out like
the plastic like mold yeah so much space
but but the thing is if you chuck out
the plastic mold and you flatten the box
okay Dan yeah when you like move house
you can just open the box up again glad
I'm too lazy so much time and money and
like possibly like the risk of like
ruining a figure in mid move and like
that save me so much trouble when I move
to my current house so that's why I hold
onto it all right okay yes I stayed for
repurposing solid purchases though
overall great the next my favorite anime
Full Metal Alchemist I recommend you
guys watch that favorite character from
but the next store we went to was a
store that's so much okay okay what were
you what before we get to a stop what
was your guys's strategy with a stop
okay a stop is probably the store that I
go to the most just yes so I knew I
really had to spend time just like
looking around yeah because there are so
many figurines at a stop that I
legitimately have never seen anywhere
else even though they're technically
second-hand yeah yeah so I'm like okay
I'm gonna aim for those and I think I
got a decent solution because for me a
stop was the most daunting shop right
good okay so in my challenge I had to
squat ten times before get interested
smaller challenge that was easy and my
second challenge wasn't also lose
because I had to buy the most expensive
figure which we found out was like a
thousand bucks
Neal's gonna lose that so I was like I
was going into a stop just not trying to
complete any challenge we're just trying
to like buy figures that I like yeah
yeah yeah follow your heart
yeah so I kind of went [ __ ] mental
windows top I filled up my piece of
paper no no no no okay serious yeah yeah
same it okay cuz I like with a stop
there are so many figures and so many
display cases that's you don't remember
wet which ciggy which figure you saw
where yeah so my strategy was just if I
see him if I see a figure I like I'm
gonna write it down right and maybe I'll
cross that later I [ __ ] myself over so
bad because I was just like I remember
seeing you like halfway through and I
had filled up my entire yeah yeah you
hadn't even had you didn't even still
walking I was just going okay that one I
get right down right down right now and
then I got to the end and then I
couldn't remember which [ __ ] I had that
he was like is it this one I feel like I
think I think yeah so who's like
basically trying to choose between my
children's I'm like what the [ __ ] am i
crossing out right now yeah no [ __ ]
clue Wow okay yeah because yeah like for
me like a stop I knew if I wasn't
careful at a stop I was gonna absolutely
ham yeah as I usually do just like
casually so I'm like okay there's still
two stores left we're not even halfway
through this challenge so I have to like
limit myself as much as possible a taste
this so I only bought three things oh oh
oh okay how many of you how many yet I
can't remember like five six I mean
you'll see do you want to go first I
decided to like kind of go for like
smallish once so my two challenges was
the first one was really easy I had to
go up to the store Clark and asked if
they had boku no pico much which they
said they didn't thank god they know
what it was
well the guy was an English speaking
stuff so he's like is that the one where
the two guys [ __ ]
you'll see it in the video but uh the
other challenge was really easy it was
just pick a figurine that either myself
gone okano likes so obviously I went
with the one that I liked so that's
[ __ ] by the line filling glad Rob
right here so I got a unwrap this ship
but I obviously got my goddamn wife in
monogastric of course it is oh of course
it is look if I'm gonna be on this show
casually like all the freaking time
[ __ ] horse okay I need it to get my
wife is she Nova I actually don't even
have this one at home
so I guess I'm gonna go I'm just gonna
go next now because of course I followed
my heart as well so yeah IIIi knew Joey
would get a Shinobu figure cuz I saw so
many boxes that were just purely Shinobu
and I'm just like get that [ __ ] out of
me get that [ __ ] out of my face man you
might need to like hold up to the camera
because it might have been assisted with
the boxes in the way actually yeah so I
mean like what I tried to do at a stop
was at the beginning I just tried to get
I just tried to no down as many figures
as I could for under 20 bucks because I
feel I feel like anything over anything
over 20 bucks was like kind of risking
its in terms of I mean especially if
you're playing like seven figures
exactly exactly so this one's I don't
have I don't have this figure yet
because this short hair Sanjay Kihara
oh that's cute that's dude I personally
find this short hair central kawaras
figurine so much nicer than the long one
there was so many good center Gaara
figurines so it like hurts me that I had
to buy the cheapest one always I bought
them
[Music]
this is uh there was a nine hundred yen
sword online like the goods it was the
cheapest sword online figure because you
know if you're gonna buy garbage why why
care about which you know like terrible
item it is it was 900 yen I think and it
was the cheapest sword online figure oh
damn okay was this for a challenge yeah
remember I had to shout I freaking love
Sao
while buying an SEO agency yeah I will
say
that's shout wasn't a shelter that was a
in Japanese culture that was like full
it was like it was just like it was like
a gradually building volume let's get
this boy out of him okay the other two
though that I bought I think is super
freakin cool because they're too
figuring that I post a really wanted but
also it just like I think it goes
without saying don't listen to the audio
or only of this it's gonna sound
probably guys this is box opening ASL
okay let me show you the other two I got
okay this second one I got is a shounen
John oh that's so cool that's pretty fun
that's right like I've never seen this
before and I'm like I was like does this
count as a figurine probably yeah yeah
that's a piece of you know solid I mean
my mom's shown a job and that's gonna
look so cool and like the shell facade
that's I think if we had a coolest item
award because I didn't know if we could
get a cool this item okay you all agree
yeah yeah but I think we can all agree
this is the cool one of the course
figuring yeah and the other one I got is
also pretty cool it's puck from berserk
how much was that this is 980 yen oh wow
cuz every Buzzard figure I saw was so
expense
like there's there's a few figures in
the sword I found like Nana Chi the the
the little Nana Chi figure mana she was
like 250 bucks
oh yeah know the meaning of this stuff
is so explored that made an abyss thing
at a stop I probably still wouldn't have
been able to do it because I'm not gonna
spend $250 I got I got URI from Angel
Beats she was I can't remember how much
but it was between ten and I there's one
figure that I didn't get I of course
puts a guru down I have cause for salary
down and you see in my video when I'm
like trying to figure out which fit
which is which and that was like just
crossing our figures the realization
when I had crossed out Zachary was just
like my heart
[ __ ] sank man my heart sank when I
was like oh
oh no I crossed us a girl how could I oh
my god don't don't look at what I'm
humbled I mean I mean that's this this
is essentially all I bought at a stop I
think I spent I didn't even spend $100
at a stop I think because yeah I spent
nine thousand nine hundred and forty and
at a stop because this shounen jump one
was 5,000 yen it's kind of expensive but
not too bad I mean I just try to get
syndra's is like Miriam Mirren's I don't
to say I bought the single best figure
[Music]
$30.00 Mike Wazowski is so cool that's
actually like that's I know cuz I saw
Mike Wazowski I'm like ado shouting I
was like Mike what are you doing here so
I have it was a $30.00 purchase and I
just wanted to make you guys laugh yeah
I I can see that that's good for
actually why I love this dude I love how
like the base is the monsters in Claudia
yes that's so cool I bought it for a
troll but I actually thought it's not
bad no that's actually I think our
audience can appreciate that that's so
cool do you have any more figures Connor
I have plenty hot key figures yeah I
mean I'm all out so I'm just gonna watch
you guys you keep talking yeah Meg am in
my life cool she was a cheap I think
she's like 19 bucks make me some mega
mint agree it's a pretty big figure like
the form factor of this box it's pretty
deceiving
that's what do you notice about a mega
mint figurines and some of them are like
way cheaper than what they should be
it's it's hard to tell the difference
between an $80 mega man figure and a $20
maybe like you know it's up with some of
the popular characters there's like so
many different prices yeah yeah with
some of the popular characters because I
think I was about to buy I was gonna buy
darkness as well oh I thought Joey was
gonna buy Mega Man
thought about it but I'm like I don't
need to and I reckon one of you guys is
gonna buy in so hold on hold on well
ninety point each Oh Joe figures oh wow
it's um it's funny you asked oh thank
god
thank God I would just like to preface
that that was not a scripted cuz we were
just showing figures and I remember
thinking I I say in the video okay
Connors gonna buy Joe Joe figures I
don't need to buy it I don't need to buy
any Joe Joe figures yeah so if you
didn't buy any I would have been like
how did we go an entire [ __ ] trip to a
key Harbor without buying any joke boy
multiple Jared your fingers actually
because it's all sides okay good good on
Brad so this is the figure that I've
actually never seen before this is the
crazy diamond George a figure and it's
the one of the special colored editions
actually I think is the there's a normal
colored version and I've never seen this
figure before and I've never seen it
listed anywhere or anything but there's
two of them in the store funny enough I
hope somebody like 19 bucks for 19 bucks
that's a really nice figure and if
you've seen Joe Joe figures you know
they look ABS a charge a lot more for a
lot less effort it's it's tragic that
like a 20-buck figure for the special
call edition is like way better than I I
paid a hundred 20 also like enjoyed your
figures it's like a double-edged sword
is that like some of them just look like
absolute ass some of them do not look
like the character tonight and it's kind
of tragic it's like one of the most
influential and popular series in Japan
and they do them dirty but it's a good
thing we can agree on that that is a
beautiful figure my boy should I show my
next figure that I bought I bought a lot
of they stop for 10 this is war dude I
knew whose ACCA's before we left the
store I and I don't know if we got this
on camera I don't think we did Joe he
was like I was gonna buy this figure and
he pointed to the booth where I got this
figure he was like oh I must spend in
the different booth and I was thinking I
bought the moment like I looked over it
was like a comic I was like I looked
over and it was just gone my head I'm
just like someone bought it it is how
much that cost it was like 30 bucks 30
bucks
oh cool that is for 30 but it is so it
is not standing up I
realizing now okay good like do you see
cure figure no yeah never [ __ ] steal
okay absolutely
that's very cool oh now it's standing up
yeah I guess now yeah this is my last
figure I of course I wanted to fill this
channel with some degeneracy just you
know what you just the question is how
much was I willing to spend on it are
you kidding me yes really yeah yeah oh
my god do you want to know how much I
spend figure I think I don't think I
walked past and I think I remember it
being way over my budget how much this
was $170 when I saw it I was like I
gotta get this cuz you know you know
that mean when it's just like how to
help me budget this correctly when I was
going through the sheet I was like
crossing off figures and Sydney was like
just get rid of the [ __ ] highschool
DxD getting rid of the high school I
walked past this figurine had my video
and I was like I would get this okay if
it wasn't a hundred and seventy dollars
because I didn't want to go overboard
but the moment I saw and I'm like one of
these ones that feel when I realize that
I don't have the most expensive figure
yeah oh this is in two parts okay so I
was trying to put that together under
underneath okay okay yeah what's what is
this oh sure yeah figures okay is this
uh is this the dragon from slime it is
indeed yes my parts holy [ __ ] I didn't
realize that we'd that fly line would be
representing this much because honestly
like I didn't put too much thought
into what I was trying to buy there we
go this came with so many oh I'm so glad
I'm so glad you got a reamer ooh so wow
that's so cool yeah wait till we build
it but like this was a two-in-one figure
I don't know if that counts as me buying
two figures or if it's I paid one but
it's true I mean that's technically one
right
no no cuz they're not actually joined
yeah they were sold to get oh my god
yeah so guess how much I paid for these
two yes
20 bucks I pay 30 bucks for the both of
them okay because I originally said
originally had a Merriam figure and a
Rimmer figure which is 35 bucks
no no it was like it was like a bundle I
dragon no no she's real nice oh no KOCO
with Miriam and then I decided to go
against that just to go from a rim so
I'm glad that we don't have a single
like character that's like overlap yeah
yeah I'm surprised cuz I thought I
thought at this point we would at least
have like some dupes
or characters but we've miraculously
somehow come over help add where's his
head not going in what [ __ ] this wing is
not going in either but yeah I sold me a
faulty thing I'm jerking those variants
so is that everything you ball Connor my
finger gone I spent money on that but
yeah I thought you know I knew I knew
falling apart
I knew one of you were gonna get a slime
figure yeah so I thought you know I'll
get it cuz I thought also it's super
blue yeah I thought that would look sick
on the podcast so like how much did you
spend on we'll find out later because I
store where I spend the most I thought I
thought because when I finished uh when
I finished go through the store I
thought that I had at least bought the
most figures in this door because I saw
Joey's horn and I was like I got this I
got a son I realize how many figures you
boards yeah you watched my next figure
than sure oh yes Thank You Bank ECB row
17 bucks
what 7 17 17 and that face is not bad
that's a damp though that is like one of
more accurate showed you figures that
I've seen Rocky's favorite as well yeah
yeah that is a nice figure yeah look at
that like swing that's a good [ __ ] to
do I can't get this [ __ ] his head
just does not want to come on I have
three more Ori more anymore oh my god
give give me the next one else I'm sorry
I'm not gonna look at what it is I'm
just gonna I know right it's so hard
okay we should give it to our producer
meline to put together right
Mylene would you like to put together
the figure for us yeah yeah give it to
me Lynn all right so my next figure oh
yes my follow you eyeing us Levi sitting
on a couch just doing leave my things
like I just like holding okay oh okay
yeah just Levi sitting on a couch I
thought it would look so like nice only
on the set and also it's best boy Levi
like course okay that's beautiful figure
yeah yeah that's actually really nice
likes expensive figure though I'm not
gonna lie really whoa but I had to kiss
like Levi sitting down was that the most
expensive figure you boy they stopped
them at a stop yes okay overall not
overall I don't think it matters because
there's this oh yeah I didn't get to
that and I got close to that yeah yeah I
know so that's Levi sitting like I just
cute I love a window figurines have like
interesting bases yeah yeah like it just
makes it seem so much more alive I want
with it
alright we're still going with like oh
god damn girl
Jesus that's cool don't you think it's
awesome I want to say 15 dolls yeah 5
bucks 5 bucks are you serious I've no no
no cuz like they say the thing about oh
no oh heck see that's that to bundle
with yeah so that we've we've got we've
got the whole slime bundle Oh
do I go through five bucks I thought you
never seemed like I love it when they
make figures of characters than all
domains yeah because they're always like
really rare than normally super
expensive the fact this was five apart
because they were like a billion Oscar
figures every single I even galleon yeah
this last one it is indeed man you you
all I think I might have won the most
figures I want a single handily with
just this nut I've I think you've bought
more figures in this store than I have
overall yeah I think so too
I won't look I want I should have gone
more ham at a stop cuz I was surprised
with you you know was deals at a
stoplight yeah yeah for the last figure
let me get these out of the way
oh nice I just thought it was a cool
figure I think it was like yeah like 30
40 bucks I mean you guys will have a
look at that yeah yeah that was my final
figure at a stop I think I got quite the
[ __ ] hole yeah you did Jesus Christ I
mean I just can't get over this that is
some one of the nicest fit I was eyeing
this and I'm just like isn't do I commit
to the podcast or do I just buy this for
myself know that that figure [ __ ] me
over for the rest of the day but you
know what was worth it damn it it was
worth it I bowels like along now from
now on after this episode you get to
[ __ ] stare at this beautiful thing in
the background every singing to monetize
every episode is because of a Reese's
[ __ ]
alright so with that giant hole all the
way by right so let's go with the third
way how much did you spend
I stopped I spin I mean I spend less
than a hundred dollars at a store my
most expensive thing was the jumps thing
right here which was 50 bucks that's
cool as [ __ ] though it is cool as [ __ ]
two hundred and twenty bucks
oh my god [ __ ] exactly I spent because
one of the challenges was whoever spends
the most at a single store gets a point
what was actually we can figure out yeah
we
IIIi OS I also spent 220 bucks oh it's
gonna go down to the tiny Emeril's nyet
all right but the third store we went to
was cables k books much like a lot of
stores in the Virgil kcon building they
sell figurines but they also sell a
bunch of light other much like figurines
plushies just little knickknacks and
stuff like yeah um
so remember oh no I do remember exactly
what I bought two things yes okay so
let's let's talk about strategy first so
what was your guy's a strategy going
into cave K bugs this was the point
where I started considering how much
money I have left
Aesop it was like spend Spanish because
I felt like I was too behind it had
animate yeah so I went ham in a stop and
then uh this is when I was like okay
maybe I should start like being careful
I was the complete opposite at this
point I had more than half of my budget
left
oh my so I was gonna go like big big
bucks boy on K books and the final army
army what would you buy I got two okay
one of my challenges was to get in a
stall for figurine right I don't know
why super specific but I found one a
stole faux figurine didn't even come it
because what happened right who was to
those two you didn't find because
because we were walking past there and I
was I saw the Estelle full figure yeah
and I just I was just like putting loads
of other figures on corner come look at
this I got this and I didn't I didn't
see the second one so there was another
one so I like waited ahead and I watched
him as he was going through it and he
actually found another one but the one
that you buried he didn't find ya oh
damn it the kiss he always got me with
that conspiracy but then the second one
I got oh the second challenge was to
find a car kept a soccer figurine
unfortunately I couldn't find one but I
know that if I went to K books like six
months ago
you don't like soccer I did the new
soccer was still like hot and fresh in
everyone's minds I don't know what it
found one well so I gave up on that so
instead I
bigboy dollars and god Oh hold your
stinky figurine cool I'm like I'm not a
huge fan of Tanya personally by oh yeah
this is a [ __ ] cool that's an awesome
figurine yeah like that this was a
hundred and thirty two dolls oh okay
with an interchangeable head book every
episode we're changing the head I'd say
that I'll have to do it but that's
pretty much the only two things I bought
yeah cuz at this point I was just trying
to stay alive they stopped it stopped
really fun with you spend how much are
they stop and then you also spend a [ __ ]
ton of anime yeah yes so I had I think I
budgeted it it's like I think I could
only spend around 70 bucks or something
or maybe less in each store so I had to
complete the challenges which was
getting a figure from a shown in Syria
oh my god I mean I already knew I'd lost
this point so I didn't really but what
surprised me because I I wasn't really
familiar with K books so I didn't know
what kind of merchandise they had yeah
they did not they did not have a lot of
shown in figure no that's all right it
was between this one and a leafy one and
I just went for the cheapest one because
I needed what I challenged I wanted to
challenge was to buy something lewd
right that was not difficult as there
was a gigantic hentai see the like I
bought like I think like half of the
source was just like 18 so I'm like I'm
like this is big remote what what lewd
thing can i buy that's really cheap and
can keep me on budget so john alter john
old horse I just okay I need I was I was
more focused on find finding a cover
which wouldn't get us easily like which
just wouldn't get this video off the
what am I too much do you monetize yeah
that's big brain youtuber boy but I did
buy one more okay but I just checked it
before we start recording I don't think
I can show of blood
get all reaction yeah yeah maybe mood on
just put like a huge black screen over
whatever God brings out so I bought
dakimakura where are we gonna blow I
thought we could just hanging up on the
wall that was like the intent we're not
gonna be able to use this because I was
like I need to buy dakimakura me survive
so I bought the cheapest what I could
find I'm like it was in it was in the
section where there weren't many like
the dark mark was one elude there were
some ludes there were some one and
they're all like covered up with this I
couldn't I couldn't tell how lit the
dark matter is were I just chose the
cheapest one black all of that out like
all of this they sell that this wasn't
this wasn't even in the hentai section
okay can I ask no can I ask because you
got the cheapest one how much was that
forty bucks and that's the cheapest
forty bucks
the cheapest one bro I got like a Sens
one at home that was like a tenner so I
my two challenges were by Oh Jojo figure
and do the pose again I was really lucky
that there was any one Jojo fear which
I'll show you shortly
I got the other one was by a wall scroll
now there was a bunch of cheap wall
Scrolls like four hundred five minute I
thought I should pretty get one from a
show that I actually like yeah yeah so I
spent ten bucks
oh I love cuts on I got that yes my
favorite shows totally under it so many
people haven't seen it as well everybody
sees has seen the show says it's [ __ ]
amazing yeah it is it is and if you
haven't seen it it's like it's my show
issue yes a good Quentin Tarantino anime
yeah it's so [ __ ] people like people
who haven't seen our just like you're
messin wit which season of Monica's yeah
it's nothing to do with the Monica three
series it's amazing yeah please watch it
that's pretty bad memories become yeah
watch it again I don't know
I got a Jojo figure I'll be good
Jojo one know which one because I
remember when you got the when you got
the challenge and you're like by a Jojo
figure I was like this mother you got so
lucky with the challenge I did the only
reason why you got 4 points is because
all of them was so easy yeah except okay
and the last stall which I'll talk about
that oh yeah a little annoying someone
but yeah so I got John Logie of our
golden experience oh it's okay I'm not
gonna lie
his face doesn't look like you get with
Jojo figs but at least we got another
Jojo figure 9 so I'm the one who did all
the hard work so what's that three now
it's Rohan sixty-six box and that's like
tonight say that yeah yeah and to be
honest with you sixty-six box is kind of
like cheap for Jo Jo friggin yeah yeah
the more I look at this face the more
hilarious again we'll take a picture of
this and show it I would describe as a
manga accurate but yeah I mean more like
Ken doll yeah yeah I mean I was just
like I swear my challenge is to bet my
got much having just done and I was like
I just want just on a mission to D
monetize this channel that was my
mission now why it will do that I was
worrying cuz like I I went into K books
and how many how many thinking like I'm
gonna buy a two hundred dollar figure
yeah yeah k books quickly ruin that plan
right challenges so I spent seventy
seven bucks on just my challenge yeah
yeah and then obviously I realized when
I drop to a Miami which what about now
yeah I challenge that I had to do as
well yeah yeah so for me I'm Yami was
just I was just trying to survive I was
I think III figured out I had like 60 I
think $60 or $50 60 bucks
what yeah yeah I was just at this point
I was just praying and hoping like I'm
wishes [ __ ] $40 on a budget pillowcase
okay part of the challenge wanted ad
obviously macaron okay you're like
Gamble's all his money's amazing I just
don't understand why I got the money all
the time man it sucks more because like
I because I knew this would be my only
opportunity to buy a document of course
why did you want to buy one sir badly
[ __ ] the pot of trash taste that's
why look it's good trash taste for a
reason we have a lot of me we had a lot
of blank space in the background where
we can hang one up so I was like
dakimakura I think that's a good
purchase and now I bought one wasted $40
can't even use it [ __ ] brilliant
gonna be a black bar I've got one at my
house I'd rather pillow the dakimakura
pillow so really I mean I've got one of
shoes of course but uh with me for army
army this is where I spent the most
amount of money cuz I have almost like I
think I had like two thirds of my budget
still left because I knew I've been into
umm yummy before not the one in the
Dajjal cake on that we went to but
there's another one in October why don't
you spend a lot of money on I spent a
lot of money there and I know they have
some really expensive figuring oh yeah
but they have a huge selection as well
so I knew I was gonna find something
hopefully good I mean that's before this
but my two challenges I believe was buy
a plushy a character plushie okay and
the other one I don't remember what it
was but I got okay I needed to you know
spend my money goes yeah yeah exactly so
I got Mughal and Final Fantasy and Final
Fantasy 7 remake out of it that's cute
alright give out JRPG love us some love
as well yeah so I got that and the most
expensive figuring I've got overall Oh
more expensive oh okay okay
is did you buy this purposely to like I
bought this purposely to get as close to
$500 as well oh okay so this is not part
of the challenge yeah I got lucky
couldn't me from daily life oh nice I
mean again this is kind of gonna be like
rias in the sense that like possibly do
I know took sucky figurines can offer
for some reason so expensive yeah I mean
she's a really popular table life
character which 141 what is expensive is
the rear software he lost that challenge
body
IIIi may have overheard or saw what Joey
was when he was buying that one yeah and
I thought all I gotta do is beep 1300
yeah I literally just went over 1300 my
expensive figure reveals soon okay okay
okay because yes that was everything you
bought and that's everything I bought
okay because for me amiami was a
stressful experience not because of the
story the story itself is great but
because I saw my challenges which was
one find an Avery Evangelion figurine um
that was a lot harder than I initially
gave it credit yeah yeah because I
missed the entire figure section right
at the back Sarge necks yeah yeah we
were just walking around and there was
one figure I found which was $200 no
actually no way that I could buy that
figure yeah and the I found another
figure which was fifty bucks
I've no no fifty to seventy bucks but I
that was the tiny bill budget this this
this girl [ __ ] me so hey I mean she's
a succubus that's luckily I found an
oscar pop figure because it was the
cheapest okay I think this is gonna be
awarded for the most Normie no offense
if you like pop vinyls but we know no
offense if you do like let's look at hey
pop figures oh Jesus how much you spent
on this 14 bucks you know what it's like
it's it's like you go to like hey you
come to Japan right you have all these
amazing figures yeah it's like go into
like a like Germany and being like I
want hot dogs from the can please I want
I want not none that starts like gonna
Germany me like can have an Asahi
No yeah I'll give you for the challenge
yeah it was for the challenge instead
like like this army ami had a lot of
good figures yeah I really really wanted
to buy I just needed to go for the
cheapest okay and then the second one
which I had no idea how to complete was
by a furry and like 100% non humanoid
figure and I was like okay the only
thing I could [ __ ] think of was
chopper from one piece yeah yeah yeah
did not have any chopping oh my gosh I
was like I've probably lost this and
then I was like mmm wait a minute that's
there's probably there's probably one
thing I could I could twist and that's a
heavy figure okay okay I was like okay
if I can't go the chopper route maybe I
can go the Pokemon routes because I
guess that's how they translating
Japanese they realize that there's a way
cuz when you pulled that out yeah I
thought you were gonna get one of these
yeah yeah cuz I didn't think those kind
of does a figure I thought but I'm like
V's furry it's nonhumanoid it's a figure
shut the [ __ ] up I am getting that
points okay okay okay that's back count
tell us that counts because there was
between like Eevee and Mewtwo I think I
was like yeah he's cuter so yeah what
are the challenges that you had Connor I
had by three anime mugs or glasses ass
because they've other sets or anything
yeah it's buy them separately yeah yeah
and then it was also by a figure that
you think is trash so we're how much
budget that you have left at this point
140 something also you Alan set out
pretty wall between the four stores yeah
because I BAC spent nothing at anime I
spent 70 bucks a K books so I kinda like
did pretty good at budgeting by accident
like I didn't plan anything I think not
having challenges that [ __ ] me over
was yeah yeah yeah that was definitely
hopeful yeah shitty summary oh yeah yeah
no it was like 220 yen as well which my
sheepish figure is is
Ida who the [ __ ] is the center your
character does anyone know I think I
know what you know I know like the what
that's cool
okay I know time I'll go warm the egg
one oh good I liked it yeah yeah yeah I
don't see Hello Kitty but I bought from
sure that was a hundred yen luckily Wow
every other mug was like a thousand yen
like nice to find two for 600 yen so we
have more mugs now for the podcast right
get all drink from those possibly maybe
never
I don't know these are like there's the
mark so I did the challenge is cool and
then I had and I was like so annoyed
because the is a frothy figure the one
with like the cool comic book text I saw
one I saw that well I had just enough
budget to get that if it wasn't for this
[ __ ]
so I had to completely change my mind
I'm not saying the stuff is bad but it
ruined my plan yeah so I had to go with
different I mean I guess you get what
you pay for right that's all that's a
like there's 100 yen for a reason you
know what what series is this I have no
idea oh no it's all characters on the
back and then these are from oh yeah
they look like a timer I don't watch or
play any or tell my games I know that
huge here in Japan but I mean for a
female demographic yeah I was just
prefer yaoi just straight up yeah don't
like you had come out with a yaoi like
manga I think you would have won like
cool the final figure and most expensive
figure that I bought right Oh si si o si
- si si si - what happened same thing
that's her like on the bike that's yeah
that's cool that's a I should get out so
you guys can fully appreciate me to go
but yes is that that was a hundred and
thirty seven thirty honestly worth every
penny
okay so while they were opening these
figurines up I guess I just want to ask
you guys like how was the challenge like
overall like do you have a good feeling
I
more stuff by the way are you add more
stuff okay oh yeah we should oh okay
we should also preface as well that
there is like consequences for the final
scores and yes basically whoever has the
lowest score at the end like including
the start the points that we got in our
individual videos as well as the points
that we're gonna add up at the end of
this episode this one has to do some
kind of punishment in a traditional
really sadistic Japanese way we
basically gonna be consuming something
that we personally don't don't really
want to consume with these two because
they're absolute [ __ ] they're gonna
have to eat one packet of knock door
which is like Japanese fermented
soybeans it's disgusting I love it
smells horrible
okay I love it thank you very much I
grew up with it
so obviously I'm not gonna eat that if I
lose I'm gonna have to eat the spicy
noodles that I ate in my Jojo quiz video
which you can go check out on my channel
yeah but we're gonna find that out at
the end of the episode once we've
calculated all the scores but I guess in
the meantime as well let us know down in
the comments below so far what is the
favorite figurine that you saw it'sit's
my one I know most likely it's gonna be
this one I'm like so happy I bought that
now because I brought it on pure
instinct right I wasn't trying to win
the game I didn't have any [ __ ]
strategy in mind you were horny on MAME
I was just 40 on main and I just wanted
everyone to see just saying so has the
bigger Dom truck yeah yeah now I know
gone is gonna [ __ ] himself now but the
rest of my purchases were to get that
even 500 bucks okay Sarge bought like a
[ __ ] aren't even and this is what is
that what is that I just guess I'm a
door knob I think of something it's like
an arm in let me let me open this a
towel of some some some money Tony it
was a hundred yen towel what is this
show that's the POV anime where like the
cute girls like work out yeah
it's so bad I love it
I got some scroll from some show wow you
really like that why did someone have
like a challenger yet to buy wall squall
I was from a different Oh trading cards
for 210 yen what is this what is this oh
wait you can put something in here well
hopefully it for like tickets maybe some
like that train tickets
maybe concert tickets its man you know
if you don't know if you want like to
know who is it weird movie you just put
this on like a track everything I bought
and it came out through an even 500
exactly oh are you serious
hang on 500 [ __ ] I did the exact I had
this footage this in my video which you
guys didn't see I went to the cashier
and I went 10 yen over so I asked the
guy I'm like no no take all the stuff
out I'm going back and they were all so
confused they're like what's he trying
to say I'm like you kick up rid of the
stuff I gotta go back so I went and
found exactly what it was good the maths
on the spot went through my camera
footage to find out what I spend at
least roll oh my do exactly 500 bucks I
was like I don't think there's anyone
that's gonna get close to $500 like at
all like if I can get as close as I can
to 500 then I think I probably won so I
think my overall price came to 49
thousand eight hundred and forty so I
was 160 yen off because for me I was
like after a stop I had just stopped
calculate I was not even uh I I died
like I was like I'm probably gonna go
bust probably gonna go bust and lose the
entire thing but no I - came out to
47,000 150 - yeah which is like four
hundred seventy dollars that's how we do
that's how we we should probably explain
that we are calculating it by dollars by
just dividing by a hundred yeah so I
guess for the first challenge of whoever
can get closest to $500 those two points
are gonna go to call hell yes that means
I'm the holy [ __ ] there's 10 points damn
I was so confident that I was like I
thought like all both of you were gonna
get like yeah I'm like not a hundred
sixty wait I got this yeah Jerry seems
so confident when we were filming that I
thought
the exact same things I got like exactly
Lucas cuz this [ __ ] he was like I
thought he'd planned everything right
name same I talked to him off screen he
turned up smiling and everything yeah
he's like I got my strategy for each
door I'm like I'm no I did not like a
good game of poker you're gonna be
overcome whatever you bluffed me into
being exact with my money I wouldn't
have done that if I didn't know that you
might have been a guy I didn't think you
were gonna like pile this small [ __ ]
forget exact I wanted to get those two
points age what I don't want to eat
[ __ ] I can't well then that was huge
so let's go over the next couple of
challenges I think there's ten left yeah
so the second one is the most expensive
figure obviously that goes on and this
done that was one hundred and sixty uh
hundred hundred and sixty thousand yen
767 170 box by one and then mine was 137
so Gong gets the point for that one yeah
yeah yeah next one is the cheapest
figurine I got the 220 yen figure yeah
anyone did anyone beat that no mine was
puck which is 900 Nader Oh mine was I
think I can't even [ __ ] remember it
was a thousand bucks so even if I didn't
buy that I still had the even gallier no
you still would have won even if I sir
okay the most the lowest rated series on
mal which was yours number
it's Tommy brave which is thinking that
mug and it was like two thousand three
hundred and seventy five seventeen
thousand four hundred and forty four
seventeen 1744 okay or now well give me
the point because mine wasn't berserk
which is five thousand six hundred and
eighty no whoa no oh because it's the
anime
oh hell yeah garbage anime not the mom
I'm sure if I looked at what that
[ __ ] towel was the schools might even
[ __ ] know what it is so I guess
that's not fair point to me baby
let's go yeah so the next was the most
figures bought in one store no we did
store her and no we just did ok ok well
I only bought 7i 14:10 ok I mean I think
I bought you bought small figures in a
stop I fill up the thing I bought
everything that I filled up overall not
gonna lie or you've a good selection but
I think my selection is pretty [ __ ]
strong this figures great paw of the
rest his selection is strong ok next one
most spent on one series I all of mine
was separate so I'm just gonna go off
the base that this I wholly forgot about
this one yeah wait wait no probably Joe
Joe right it could have been Joe Joe but
it wouldn't have been I spent a lot on
like attack on Titan and Joe Joe but I
didn't get anything near 160
she's just so not carrying these these
challenges alright it says we made
challenges that will reward you for
being frugal with your money yeah and
buying a little things yeah so would
reward you if you bought if you did the
gamble that paid off them oh yeah yeah
that's the game and yeah yeah cuz you
had to guess right cuz I was thinking in
my head would Joey buy $200 figure oh
yeah I thought both of you could and I
was like maybe I should just give up on
that challenge yeah just focus on
everything else cuz like I when I saw
her I was like I just want to buy her
because she's like a pretty unique
figure tips and I thought I just I saw
titty and I didn't I didn't think and
before I knew it I was writing down the
number like his wife was right there as
well if I didn't matter it was funny
because out of every figure I bought
this one was the one that I didn't think
about the most I was getting this figure
I'm not even gonna think about it my god
the most spent on a nun figure well for
me it would be I guess which is 2,800
Mama's wife 1001
okay mine was a document yes forty bucks
on it
if being a degenerate [ __ ] save me in
this game I'm so [ __ ] happy yeah
what's the next are the most next one is
most faint in once how much did you
spend exactly an a stop I spent one
hundred and ninety seven dollars where'd
you spend twenty two thousand three
hundred and eighty yen I spent twenty
two thousand one hundred and ninety come
on come on come on
okay here we go okay closest to 69
closest to $69 this was this was the
mean one this is all right for me it was
the short jump thing which was four
thousand nine hundred and eighty n okay
mine was nowhere near mine was the
Edward Elric one yeah
which was five thousand two hundred
ninety nine I win
$66 baby Oh on the jointer Giavanna one
funny Oh so the one that I had no choice
to buy don't me another point so sweet
oh my god I'm gonna [ __ ] lose alright
no Meah below me award so whoever has my
highest rank on mal loses a point I
think I lose this right did you what did
you go attack on Titan
whatnot is that higher than attack on
Titan is number two I think if I look
what I lost
number one is death no that's no
definite okay I'm definitely say most
minds according to according to my enemy
list it's death note shingeki no kyojin
sort online then full metal alchemist
lose that one cuz cuz I could because I
saw my boy Levi where is he was it
beautiful here like I couldn't oh I lose
a point so okay final one buying a hint
I figure okay okay okay so I'm at zero
points for me baby I'm gonna argue no no
no no no here's why I didn't I didn't
realize this but you can replace
Reese's tits to be uncensored are you
serious yeah yeah yeah I didn't know I
didn't know what that was until I opened
it up those are just nipples
I didn't know they came with
interchangeable nipples we're gonna find
that out after the yeah so light thing
they're attached to the hand yeah oh my
god I mean I would like to argue that
you buying the dakimakura already counts
as like a thigh thing but that wasn't a
figure but III think that uncensored
nipples counts as a hentai figure
because we condone but but is it though
cuz it's highschool DxD it's not
technically hand tie I mean if there's
tits out there is it a hentai figure I
mean I would like to argue that if it's
something we can't show yes Paul if it's
something we can't show on this podcast
which I have okay this isn't a hint I'm
so [ __ ] good only a single figure in
clutch oh my god okay and the total
scores were Connor with 12 points got
with 12 points and I got 7 points why I
would have won this if I didn't buy the
attack on tiny figures by the way I
woulda won this if I was actually smart
probably would have lost this if I
didn't buy this one it was also your
downfall
yeah well it also more positives than
negatives because when we were like
going through all the challenges because
we had complete forgotten the overall
challenges and I was like wait a minute
like I think this one figure could be a
lot of these challenges yeah I'm like I
totally forgot we put hentai figure in
there would have bought a shitty one if
I was like it would have been hard good
there's not any hentai figures no no cuz
all of the hentai figures were like
hundreds of dollars
yeah they mean you know it's a very
cultured I'm I just like to point out
that I over all of these like overall
challenges I only know one point and
that was the fact that puck is the
lowest rated out of everything here I
think the thing is that he went all out
with that yeah I was a bit more
conservative spread my money out you
know you went like mid range
hey I'm buying kind of expensive but no
this is like I like this [ __ ] I'll just
buy it this is what happens when you try
to strategize I will at least like the
credit of probably getting the coolest
no no you use cool that's cool you can
have that point yeah I'll have that put
up that face I'm not gonna win the pity
points cookie this is such a nice figure
alright well since I lost I guess I have
to eat a horrible thing I think I'll
produce a Maylene brought something yeah
which I am NOT looking forward to eating
well that already I that I I can't even
smell it but I can picture one of his
mouths like thank you may lean our
amazing producer yeah alright well my
challenge has arrived
hey it's ty so what what is this it's a
pickled mudfish so apparently according
to our producer this smells awful
apparently is just as bad if not worse
than surstroemming which is like pickled
I think it's like mackerel filling
it's like Swedish thing that old
youtubers eat okay so I'm gonna open up
and give it a smell of a jury
yeah I'm just gonna like I just saw that
man go to heaven smells like actual
light well it I can smell it from here
on smell it like oh this looks okay I
mean we have no utensils gonna have to
get in that I think I'm I think I've
eaten that oh my god
yeah it's like okay so it's like Verdi
salted fish right so it's gonna be super
super super salty I'm just gonna grab
like a piece of it weights to show it on
camera [ __ ] show that piece on camera
yeah yeah yeah careful the boghei is
that off yeah yeah just don't get on the
microphone like Inez please gravity how
is it yes it's just salted fish right
some water because what what kills you
is the [ __ ] artist the first few
bites aren't that bad but the more you
chew it the more like the flavors come
out under the aftertaste just just it
hits you and your breath is gonna stink
for like a [ __ ] oh my god it's
[ __ ] stinks now hey guys should you
should wash it down with the durian
anything that would be a good I think
that'd be a good idea
seeing as you did lose pretty badly yeah
don't smell it maybe a jury I don't
think like I've eaten a lot of weird
foods in my life this is easily the
grossest thing I've ever had yeah yeah
smell it over there it's like a fire I
think the smells getting stronger yeah
fallout zone here it's like it's like a
nuclear blast I'm like fine if I hold my
nose because like I don't like smell the
thing but the moment I get rid smell my
own breath it's next week when we do the
podcast Joe will still be smelling it
yeah I really just hope this doesn't
give me like an illness because we're
like going on a trip to old tide people
right now
we're going on a vacation tomorrow yeah
I don't want to be sick it's gonna
[ __ ] stink it's in the windows of
infectious episode like Jesus so so now
that the challenge is over what are you
guys as closing thoughts I'm in each
little [ __ ] I mean you know the goal the
ultimate goal was was the one not lose
and become like this mani yeah yeah
going through like the five stages of
grief with his face you know we got to
decorate the office I think by a miracle
we got like some pretty good variation
oh yeah honestly would love to do some
like this again in future with another
challenge we're not going film I'm
surprised that out of all the things
that we bought not a single person
bought the same thing yeah yeah yeah
because that was the thing I was most
worried about right when I you know
pitched the challenge I was the thing I
was worried I was like what if we all
just go for the same [ __ ] figure Zaku
dendekker
I would like three of your finest deck
because because yeah I had a lot of fun
filming in the stores and I would love
to do something like this again I don't
know if you guys enjoyed seeing the
aftermath of all our different
individual challenges and how we like
approached it yeah I mean I think it's
the speak for all thing we have fun with
every step of this process I really hope
that was reflect I got to ask you though
yeah cuz this is your first time doing
like a video filming in public okay I'm
used to embarrassing myself and how was
it I got to know it was hard like
outside of animate when I was filming my
intro I don't even know if you're gonna
see that because I'm thinking about
filming like a separate intro anyway so
but I was just like tripping over my
words I had no idea yeah give me a
script great I can read off the script
if I just have to talk about my thoughts
without any scripts and like a podcast
is different in my mind's cuz I have
people to bounce off right because when
I'm looking at a camera I'm like hey
guys
I'm here outside of an anime oh my gosh
like somewhat tribal speaking skill you
learn I think yeah and I mean I always
awkward as [ __ ] I remember first but I
think I got used to it when I just it
was a stop animates I was so like
getting my feet on the ground with a
stop I was just I think it was thanks to
just the facts the places well because I
wasn't great I wasn't thinking about
what challenges there were yeah I was
just thinking about getting as many
[ __ ] fingers like I did a lot of fun
I think it was well I was like a great
environment like when you get permission
to film in a place and cuz the original
plan for this video was just to like
MacGyver away through GoPro cover that
would have not been that great yeah yeah
but I mean I haven't edited the video
yet but I think it's gonna be pretty
pretty entertaining and you guys can let
us know as well like how you guys found
those videos how you found this episode
hopefully you guys enjoyed watching me
eat literal [ __ ] this is easily the
worst [ __ ] thing I've ever had I can
still [ __ ] taste it I really want you
guys to smell your fingers I mean I
definitely even though this was like a
logistical nightmare planning that's me
about logistics from episode oh yeah
this was like actual logistical
nightmare planning all this yeah we had
to like bounce stores and it's short
notice and everything like I would
definitely be up for doing something
when it's like three angles again and
it's a challenge that we have concluded
on the problem it's like you you like
I'm not sure if you see in the video but
by the time we got to army army
I was I was exhausted like it was it was
kind of like that feeling when you've
just spent an entire day at a con
working oh yeah yeah I've got to do one
more just a con in general yeah yeah I'm
[ __ ] oh we gotta have dinner oh [ __ ]
asleep
like I remember post filming I just went
home and collapse yeah yeah I didn't
leave my bed yeah I think we won't look
10 kilometers that day yeah I checked my
like stat typical Tokyo Dave Church you
do a lot of walking when you come to
Japan yeah but I think so what was the
favorite thing you guys bought them
that's a good question
easy play for you yeah instinctively I
want to say like I mean I think it's
good it's sorted but I think the most
interesting for you and like coolest
ones I'm glad I bought was maybe the
akhira one which i thought was just so
far or the leave I want Mike Wazowski
though the name should be sad
kendo yeah that's that's a good deal I
think my favorite is definitely John oh
that's that's because it's so unique I
love unique figures yeah yeah there's so
many figures that look alike and who
doesn't like job exactly yeah I just
that's gonna that it's just gonna look
good yeah
what is okay what's the worst figure you
think each of us bought this is this
thing what the hell I don't know
actually I liked all the figurines I
bought maybe that's why I what's the
most biggie thing I bought was one you
bought or I mean you bought so many
icons
that's what yes probably you're [ __ ]
a Montague a free one that's kind of
excuse you trash tasty I do see one
small mine I have a registered weapon
now really I feel like we've adequately
roast each other's purchases yeah I
guess I guess I wanted to give a shout
out to all the stores week oh yeah
because okay so disclaimer when I have
[ __ ] on like some of the things we
bought but the stores are [ __ ] great
this business like if we shed on this
figure this isn't representative to the
what we had what they had at the store
yeah no yeah because some of them were
just we needed to buy stuff just to
fulfill the challenge I wish I could
have bought something but a pop figure
for Oscar ami ami has so many good
figures okay the army army have so many
good figures but I had to I had to
settle for this yeah all the stores were
fantastic and again like thank you guys
for like giving us permission on such
short notice yeah a bunch of really loud
youtubers as you can tell yeah and all
the sorts are right next to each other
as well so if you go there's no reason
not to go down yeah yeah they're all
like what less than ten minutes yeah no
I was just gonna say yeah and just thank
thank you for letting us film that down
below yeah and I hope you guys enjoyed
this video and the main videos again if
you haven't checked out each one of our
videos where we you'll see you know all
of our perspectives of how we came to my
all your amazing goods then again go to
the links down in description below you
can check out all three of our videos
and yeah I guess look out for all of
this stuff out somewhere right here were
you gonna shout out the patreon yeah go
ahead
they also have a patreon now this is a
very expensive ok we we we did this
challenge because we wanted to do the
challenge we want it we need just the
patreon to keep the podcast running yeah
yeah and that's pretty much it
I mean as you can tell the editing is is
you know some damn good edit shout out
to mood on yeah moving on we want to
keep hiring him and we want to keep this
all right exactly keep it at the best
quality that it possibly can and your
guys's support over on the patreon is
going to help us out a lot Joey get the
[ __ ] away from me with that dirty ass
finger I'm gonna have a Razzie for the
rest can I do the outro because I don't
want you speaking anymore can I can I
say one thing before before you do the
outro is a call back to previous episode
I imagine that's what Jerry's finger
smart like after he rated school days
I'm not over that hey guys before we
sign off I just wanted to give a quick
shout out to today's sponsors now this
is a very long name so I'm gonna have to
read it out it's sponsored by animation
ISM a project by Japan Media Arts
Festival's
oversea promotion initiated by the
agency for Cultural Affairs of Japan man
that was a mouthful that's a serious
mouthful yes but if you guys don't know
what they are they have a lot of
interviews with Japanese creators and
also with a lot of Japanese anime stood
as well and a whole lot more anyway
they're having a free anime screening
this weekend online which you can check
out in the description below so for
those of you who want to know the name
of the three anime films it is a
colorful ninja yo machi the single one
is mother saboteur of the wind and the
third one is simply titled Rebecca so
basically these are three films from the
young animator training project and if
you've ever watched something like death
billiards or the original mimimi those
are films that came from this project so
by watching them you can support the
anime industry and that's [ __ ] awesome
in my opinion so if you are interested
in the art of Japanese culture and
animation then make sure to go down to
the links in the description below and
thank you once again for sponsoring
today's episode so anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed this episode we've been
crashed ace he's got trash mouth or
trash in his mouth right now I am still
surprised that we in Connor drawn
because Thank You Riza for like [ __ ]
Sylar carrying this playthrough for me
big titties big titties for the win and
we'll see you guys next time bye bye bye
you could argue that shounen jump is is
actually not a figure just saying like I
mean then I would look I already lost
alright but I wanted to get the doll
he's already dead
[Music]